Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
C'est dommage, c'était bien jusque-là...
(Rires)
Bon, que dire ?
Je vais essayer de dire un petit peu...
Je vais essayer de dire quelque chose.
Ne vous attendez pas à ce que je dise
quelque chose d'intelligent.
Déjà c'est difficile,
mais en plus j'ai plutôt la réputation
de dire des conneries, donc...
Puisque vous me donnez cette
opportunité, je vais la saisir,
mais avec tous les intervenants
qui sont passés -
À chaque fois qu'on intervient
quelque part, il y a toujours un connard.
Quand je vois la qualité de
ce qui est passé jusque-là,
j'ai le pressentiment -
je ne sais pas pourquoi -
(Rires)
que le connard, ça va être moi.
(Applaudissements)
Puisque j'ai ce rôle,
que je peux tout dire,
mais que je ne m'y étais pas
spécialement préparé,
je vais dire ce que j'ai ressenti.
Je pourrais peut-être
commencer en parlant de...
d'envoyer un message à l'organisation.
C'est un petit peu bizarre, mais
maintenant que je suis sur scène...
Là ça va, les gens me regardent,
là aussi, là aussi,
mais au fond, il y a des gens
qui regardent la télé.
(Rires)
C'est bizarre.
Du coup, je me demande :
« C'est quoi cette salle ? »
L'an prochain pourquoi pas l'organiser
dans une piste de bobsleigh
tant que vous y êtes ?
(Rires)
Alors... c'est vrai....
(Applaudissements)
Je vais commencer en disant
qu'au début, j'étais un peu déçu
quand vous avez expliqué la différence
entre les conférences TED et les TEDx
car secrètement je pensais
que c'était la qualité des TED
mais en parlant de pornographie...
(Rires)
Heureusement, certains
intervenants l'ont abordée
parce que sinon je pense
que j'aurais été hyper déçu...
(Rires)
Et puis finalement,
il s'est passé plein de choses.
Donc on peut peut-être faire ça :
peut-être dire ce que j'ai ressenti
en regardant les [intervenants].
Il y a des trucs qui étaient bien, mais
il y a des trucs quand même...
(Rires)
Hein ? Bon !
On va commencer par la première :
Joanna.
Joanna, franchement moi,
j'ai pris une grosse claque,
parce que Joanna, tu as dit
à un moment donné :
« Souvenez-vous du moment où vous
avez réalisé que vous alliez mourir. »
Merci bien, mais je ne
l'avais pas encore réalisé.
(Rires)
Donc déjà, j'ai passé 10 minutes
à bader dans mon coin.
(Rires)(Applaudissements)
Et après, comme si elle n'avait pas
enfoncé le couteau assez loin,
elle nous parle de la petite
boule qu'elle a dans la gorge.
Je trouve que ça aussi,
ce n'est pas très sympa de le dire.
Il faut penser à son public
quand on dit des trucs.
Franchement, qui n'a pas l'habitude
d'avoir des boules dans la gorge,
si ce n'est les supporters
du Stade rennais ?
(Rires)
Il y a des lieux pour dire les choses.
Qu'est-ce que tu as dit encore ?
Ah oui, après, tu as parlé
de tes vacances en Malaisie.
C'est vrai que ce moment-là m'a rappelé
mes vacances au camping des Flots.
Arrivé là-bas, je m'étais aperçu
que j'avais oublié mon maillet.
Gros choc !
J'avais oublié mon maillet,
j'étais hyper embêté,
je me suis posé des questions :
« Comment je vais
enfoncer mes sardines ? »
J'ai commencé à faire le tour de ma tente,
j'ai essayé avec une chaussure
mais il y avait un caillou.
Je pensais : « Ça va pas du tout. »
Puis j'ai vu que personne n'en mettait,
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de vent.
Je m'en suis tiré et j'ai compris
que j'avais eu accès au bonheur.
Même sans maillet !
(Rires et applaudissements)
Je continue dans l'ordre
où ils apparaissent.
Jean-Philippe.
Jean-Philippe, sans déconner,
tu ne peux pas dire des trucs comme ça.
Tu es là Jean-Philippe ;
tu m'as fait pleurer,
c'était hyper émouvant, merci beaucoup.
Tu m'as fait bander aussi, après.
(Rires)
Par contre, avec tout le respect
que je te dois, j'ai été ultra touché,
je ne pensais pas qu'un
handicapé pouvait être aussi touchant.
(Rires)
Par contre il faut que
je t'explique un truc.
J'en profite parce que
ça peut servir à d'autres.
Je sais, on a parfois envie
d'écrire des lettres à des gens,
mais il y a plus simple que
d'inviter 600 personnes pour les lire,
alors que les gens sont là.
Tu peux utiliser la Poste
et leur envoyer, tu vois,
plutôt que convier autant de monde.
En plus, on n'a pas tous eu notre lettre,
j'attendais la mienne avec impatience.
(Rires)
Moi non plus,
je ne suis pas fan des commodes,
mais ça, ce n'est pas tellement grave.
(Rires et applaudissements)
Après, il y a eu Olivier.
Olivier a expliqué :
quand il n'arrive pas à faire un truc,
que les ordinateurs non plus,
il le fait faire aux gamins.
(Rires)
C'est vachement intéressant parce qu'ils
jouent, ils ne s'en rendent pas compte.
Ils s'amusent et ils résolvent
des trucs importants.
J'ai donc une suggestion
pour la prochaine expression :
comme ni les ordinateurs, ni les adultes,
on arrive à le résoudre,
vous pourriez les faire travailler
sur les violences faites aux femmes,
ou un truc du genre...
C'est moins drôle, hein ?
(Rires)
Après qui est-ce qu'on a eu ?
On a eu Nolwenn.
Nolwenn...
Nolwenn, je suis désolé,
je ne sais pas qui a laissé crier
son gamin au début de ton talk,
(Rires)
Ça a dû complètement te perturber,
mais bon tu t'es bien reprise.
J'ai trouvé ça complètement génial,
mais je tenais à te dire que, du coup,
j'ai un problème avec ma fille,
parce qu'elle a simulé une appendicite
pour aller jouer au jeu que tu as montré.
(Rires)
Et quand ils lui ont retiré, ils ont
constaté qu'elle n'était pas inflammée.
(Rires)
Qu'est-ce qu'on a eu encore ? Michaël.
Michaël, qui nous parle de la scolarité.
Ça m'a fait un sacré choc.
Il dit :
« Souvenez-vous de votre scolarité. »
Ben ouais...
Je voulais faire ingénieur.
Mes parents m'ont dit :
« Non, tu seras comédien. »
(Rires)
J'ai tenu bon pendant un moment :
j'ai fait ingénieur, puis j'ai craqué,
j'ai fait comédien...
(Rires et applaudissements)
Après, il y a eu Bertier.
Bertier était exceptionnel ;
il a dit un truc que j'ai adoré
« À un moment donné, être différent,
on se dit que c'est dire
merde à tout le monde. »
Je trouve fou qu'il n'ait pas
profité de l'occasion
d'avoir autant de monde pour le faire.
Du coup, j'en profite un peu :
« Merde ! Merde ! Merde! »
(Rires et applaudissements)
Après, il y a eu Paul Marques-Duarte,
mais ça, c'était nul...
(Rires et huées)
Quoi ?
Mais non, bien sûr que j'ai été touché.
Paul, peux-tu m'autoriser
à utiliser ta machine ?
J'ai vu qu'elle était partie ; dommage
car j'avais un message à adresser,
peut-être pas au vieux Sébastien Chambres,
mais au Sébastien Chambres
qui avait 18 ans,
parce quand je te vois, je voudrais
me parler à moi à 18 ans :
« Dis, Sébastien, tu te rends
compte qu'à ton âge,
il y en a qui sont déjà allés à Cannes,
alors qu'est-ce que tu fous ?
(Rires)
Alors bouge-toi le cul, sinon
à 38 ans, tu vas finir à TEDx. »
(Rires et applaudissements)
Bon, et j'en oublie probablement,
je suis désolé, je ne peux pas donner
mon avis sur tout,
parce qu'il faut qu'on rentre chez nous.
En fait, ce que je regrette un peu,
c'est que vous ne m'ayez pas donné
l'opportunité de jouer avec ça.
Si vous m'aviez demandé gentiment
au lieu de me tirer au hasard,
je vous assure, je vous aurais fait une
conférence, je vous aurais fait un talk.
J'aurais fait une conférence qui
se serait appelée « Les solutions ».
Je vous aurais fait la conférence :
« Les solutions par le professeur
Sébastien Chambres ».
Bon, et ben je vais la faire,
cette conférence.
« Le professeur », c'est un petit abus,
vous m'en excuserez.
Pour que des gens intelligents écoutent,
il me fallait tricher sur ma condition.
Je me suis posé la question :
« Est-ce qu'il faut mettre une photo ? »
On m'a dit : « Il ne faut pas faire
de powerpoint quand on va à TEDx. »
En regardant ma conférence,
vous allez comprendre pourquoi.
Je me suis dit : « Peut-être qu'il faut se
présenter, je vais mettre une photo. »
Je vais mettre une photo,
oui, mais laquelle ?
Je vais mettre une photo de moi, pas très
original, mais ça me représente le plus.
Et à côté mon titre :
« Professeur des Universités », ça pète !
Parce que je pense que
ça joue vachement, en fait.
Qui les autres sont, ça joue vachement
sur le crédit qu'on va leur accorder.
Par exemple, si j'avais mis :
« Sébastien Chambres, comédien »,
qu'auriez-vous pensé ?
« Qu'est-ce qu'un comédien pourrait nous
apprendre ? Cette bande de feignasses ! »
Non, il ne faut surtout
pas que je mette ça !
Allons plus loin, si on parle de soi,
cela change-t-il l'image des autres ?
Si j'avais mis :
« Sébastien Chambres, homosexuel ».
La moitié se serait dit :
« Ben ouais, il a une chemise rose. »
(Rires)
Mais si j'avais mis
« Sébastien Chambres, schizophrène »,
les gens qui étaient assis
à côté de moi se diraient :
« Waouh, je viens de passer 4 heures et
demie assis à côté d'un schizophrène. »
Parce qu'ils ne savent pas
ce que c'est, forcément.
Et si j'avais mis
« Sébastien Chambres a fait un burnout »,
peut-être vous diriez-vous :
« C'est con, je le trouvais cool, je lui
demanderais bien de faire une conférence
mais il ne doit pas être fiable.
Pour peu que ça tombe le jour où j'ai
besoin de lui, non, du coup... râpé. »
Non, il ne faut pas que je mette ça.
Je pourrais mettre « Sébastien
Chambres sort avec une noire ».
Peut-être qu'il y a
des gens qui se seraient dit :
« Oh, moi, ça ne me dérange pas trop. »
(Rires)
Du coup, je me suis demandé :
« Qu'est-ce qu'ils auraient dit si
j'avais dit : 'qui sort avec un noir' ? »
(Rires)
Je me suis dit : « C'est quand même
cumuler un peu les mandats. »
Je me suis dit :
« Il faut que je change. »
Peut-être que je pourrais avouer
que je suis une femme,
et que je m'appelle
Sébastienne Chambresse.
(Rires)
Je devine tout ce que
vous vous diriez, du genre :
« La pauvre, la tronche qu'elle se paye.
(Rires)
Comment elle va faire
pour faire un métier de douceur
comme infirmière ou institutrice,
avec une tête comme ça ?
Et surtout comment va-t-elle
faire pour trouver un mari ?
Hein ? La pauvre. »
C'est pour ça que j'ai mis « Professeur
Sébastien Chambres, Les solutions. »
Alors, pourquoi... ben oui...
pourquoi « les solutions » ?
C'est important.
Parce qu'on parle toujours de problèmes.
La différence crée des problèmes,
on ne sait pas les gérer,
Eh bien moi, je vais régler vos problèmes
en vous apportant... les solutions !
(Applaudissements)
C'est une conférence assez courte
qui va avoir en gros trois parties.
La première :
quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ?
La 2ème : qu'est-ce que
quoi qu'on va faire pour qui ?
Enfin en 3ème partie, comment
qu'est-ce qu'on doit le faire ?
(Rires)
Peut-être vous êtes-vous
posé la question :
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'on va
le faire pour qui ? Pas intéressant.
L'important, c'est d'agir
et il faut le faire maintenant.
(Applaudissements)
Alors... quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ?
Puisque je suis un professeur,
j'ai choisi de vous faire un graphe moche.
Dessus, vous verrez deux axes.
Le premier axe :
nous allons regarder
le niveau de dangerosité des solutions.
Et sur un deuxième axe, la difficulté
à mettre en œuvre ces solutions.
Tout d'abord, difficile à
mettre en œuvre mais pas dangereux :
les avancées scientifiques.
Elles sont fabuleuses.
Ainsi, on sait que le cerveau de la femme
et celui de l'homme sont identiques,
et que c'est une question
de plastique et d'éducation.
Si vous ne savez pas faire un créneau, ce
n'est pas par manque de vision en 3D,
Tout ça, c'est des conneries.
Aussi grâce aux avancées scientifiques,
on sait que l'autisme est génétique,
et que ça n'a rien à voir avec vous ;
vous n'êtes pas coupables,
contrairement à ce qu'a raconté la
psychanalyse pendant des années.
Après ces avancées scientifiques...
Vous pouvez y aller...
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci.
C'est dur à mettre en œuvre
mais quelque chose de facile :
l'éducation, la formation, l'information.
Il suffit d'en parler, on ignore
ce que c'est, donc on en a peur
et on se comporte mal,
alors qu'il suffit d'expliquer aux gens
qu'on est tous super cool, des fois.
(Rires)
Et autre chose, c'est tout ce qu'on n'a
pas encore inventé, pas encore pensé.
Il faut toujours se laisser un peu
de place pour l'amélioration des choses.
(Rires)
Vous me direz : « Tout ceci, c'est bien
beau, parce que c'est écrasé par le FGC. »
Le FGC, le FGC qui prend...
Je n'ai pas pu le mettre à l'échelle,
pas assez de place.
Si j'avais dû mettre le FGC à l'échelle -
Les autres carrés ont la bonne taille,
mais le FGC fait à peu
près la taille de la France...
« Qu'est-ce que le FGC ? » me direz-vous.
C'est le « Facteur Gros Connard ».
(Rires)
Car il faut le savoir,
la connerie est la ressource
la mieux distribuée sur la planète.
(Rires et applaudissements)
Vous pouvez partir n'importe où
en oubliant votre connerie,
vous en trouverez sur place !
(Rires)
Et quelle que soit votre
gourmandise en connerie,
il y en aura toujours trop, donc allez-y !
Le FGC, qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être ?
Des fois, des gens qu'on aime.
Je vais vous parler
de quelqu'un que j'adore.
Si jamais tu regardes cette vidéo,
tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup.
Je veux parler de ma grand-mère.
Vous vous demandez ce que je vais
dire comme saloperies sur elle.
(Rires)
Et vous avez raison !
Ma grand-mère, quelqu'un que
j'adore vraiment, un jour a dit :
« Je rentre du centre-ville,
et j'ai vu une personne
se garer sur une place 'handicapé',
avec un macaron 'handicapé',
et la personne est sortie
de sa voiture en marchant...
Comme quoi quand même,
ces gens-là, ils abusent... »
(Rires)
J'ai expliqué qu'elle ne pouvait pas
marcher longtemps,
à cause de problèmes de dos, et que tous
les handicaps ne se voyaient pas, mais...
(Rires)
Maintenant, je voudrais
vous montrer des méthodes.
J'ai parlé de solutions,
on parle toujours des problèmes.
Je sais, ça nous est tous arrivé,
c'est pénible, on se coltine des
gens en état dépressif majeur.
Les gens dépressifs, c'est insupportable,
Eh bien, je vais vous dire
comment faire pour se comporter
avec une personne en état dépressif.
Vous vous le demandiez, eh bien,
je vous l'offre, c'est cadeau.
C'est la méthode.
Alors tout d'abord, écoutez la personne
autant que possible.
Il est important que vous puissiez faire
une investigation
pour essayer de trouver quel est son
mal-être afin de l'aider à le résoudre.
Deuxièmement, l'aider à réaliser des
tâches qu'elle n'arrive pas à faire seule
car c'est toujours hyper-valorisant
d'être aidé par quelqu'un qui demande
toujours si on arrive à faire nos lacets.
(Rires)
Troisième point :
la motiver, pour voir des gens,
pour faire du sport, penser positif,
et si besoin est, un petit coup de pied
au cul, ça ne fait jamais de mal.
Il faut bouger les gens
et se prendre par la main.
Si ça ne marche pas, diffusez
des huiles essentielles de patchouli
(Rires)
en grandes quantités - vous trouverez ça
dans la première pharmacie.
Si ça ne marche toujours pas, faites
la liste de ce qui va bien dans sa vie.
Parce qu'il faut relativiser quand même,
tout le monde a ses problèmes,
donc aidez la personne, dites-lui :
« Regarde, tu as un peu tout
pour toi quand même, alors, hein... »
Et si vraiment ça ne marche pas,
vous lui montrerez un film sur
la Shoah pour l'aider à relativiser.
(Rires)
Parce qu'il faut toujours penser
aux gens qui sont plus malheureux que soi.
Et si tout ça n'a pas marché,
vous pourrez lui lire le passage
Ezéchiel 25.17 de la Bible édition Boutin.
C'est toujours rassurant de trouver des
gens disant plus de conneries que vous.
(Rires)
Bien sûr, vous pourrez me dire :
« D'accord, l'état dépressif,
mais si je connais un bipolaire ? Ah ? »
Eh bien, rassurez-vous,
je vous dis tout ça dans mon livre
qui s'appelle
« Comment gérer les handicapés »,
bien sûr par le professeur
Sébastien Chambres.
C'est aux éditions Brasser
parce qu'il coûte horriblement cher,
mais il est vraiment bien,
il vous le faut, achetez mon livre !
Bon, bien sûr, ça, c'est des conneries...
(Rires)
Mais pourquoi je vous dis ça ?
Effectivement, je suis comédien.
Je joue dans le spectacle
« Tous pareils, tous différents »,
où on essaie de changer le regard des gens
sur les personnes en situation de handicap
parce qu'on est tous concernés.
En fait, ça, on nous le demande
quand on va faire le spectacle :
« Avez-vous un livret expliquant comment
se comporter avec les pathologies ? »
(Rires)
Ce ne sont pas des personnes.
Comment gérer les personnes ?
Ça revient au même
parce que les personnes handicapées,
eh bien, elles se gèrent
très bien toutes seules.
Donc, j'aimerais changer un petit
peu, retirer mon tablier de professeur,
et passer au citoyen S. Chambres pour
vous faire part d'une petite réflexion.
Cette petite réflexion, c'est le fait de
se rendre compte qu'à certains moments,
on est un peu tous pareils.
On est un peu tous pareils.
On a tous plus ou moins eu des cheveux.
Peut-être pas vous...
(Rires)
Quand on a faim,
on aime bien manger un truc.
Quand on a envie de faire pipi,
on aime bien aller aux WC.
Quand on est amoureux, on est content,
on en parle à tout le monde,
on se fait larguer, on tire la tête.
Il y a des moments, on est tous pareils.
Et à d'autres, on est tous différents.
Ça peut être une manière de s'habiller,
une orientation sexuelle,
une couleur de peau,
un handicap, un genre,
le pays d'où on vient,
la langue maternelle,
ça peut être n'importe quoi
mais en fait, on s'en fout,
parce que le plus important,
c'est qu'on est tous égaux.
On est tous égaux, et même les connards,
parce qu'on est quand même
tous un peu des connards.
(Rires)
Je suis un connard, je le sais très bien :
je ne réponds jamais à mes mails ;
dès que je vais quelque part,
j'arrive une heure en retard.
Mais ce n'est pas grave,
car on m'aime quand même un peu.
Tout le monde est un connard -
Vous êtes une connasse
(Rires)
Mais si... En plus, vous le savez.
Vous le savez.
Vous êtes un connard.
Ça se voit, en même temps.
(Rires)
Vous êtes tous des connards,
des connasses,
et vous qui nous regardez chez vous
vous êtes des connards et des connasses.
Vous, assis là-bas, faisant mine d'écouter
alors que vous dormez, vous l'êtes aussi !
mais ce n'est pas grave car
je voudrais vous dire quelque chose,
le plus sincèrement possible,
c'est : je ne vous connais pas...
vous êtes des connards et des connasses,
je voudrais quand même dire
ce que je pense a priori,
parce que c'est mon choix.
Pour vous dire ça, je voudrais demander
de l'aide de beaucoup de personnes,
de comédiens et comédiennes
que j'ai rencontrés à des moments.
C'est de vous dire que vous êtes
des connards mais je vous aime.
(Applaudissements)
Ich Liebe dich
Ich Lieb dich
Minä rakastan sinua
Kocham cię
Jag älskar dig
'k zien je geeren
ani ohevet otkha
'ahbak
I love you
You know what ? I love you !
I love you.
I love you
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup !